Transcriber: Fatima El Kerchaoui
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
(موسيقى)
دكتور محمد قاسم عبد الغفور
(تصفيق)
تراث انساني خارج التغطية، خارج الأحلام
سيداتي آنساتي سادتي
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
سأبدأ ليس كل المعتاد
سأبدأ من أحلام و أمنيات
سأبدأ من قصة إمرأة جميلة اسمها بغداد
سأبدأ، عندما تعجز الكلمات في مدح من أحب
أو أرثية من مات
سأبدأ ولكن هيهات
أن تنحني بغداد
بين قسوة قلب أو صخب عمارات
سأبدأ من مدن لها ملامح و هويات
أشكال و الوان وذكريات
و لكنها لا تبوح مثلما تبوح الهمسات
و كلما اتسعت بغداد
اتسعت أحلام من يسكنها و أمنيات
يقال إن المدينة
التي تدفعك إلى التفكير في المستقبل
هي مدينة عظيمة
و لذلك عليك أن تنصت لها جيدا
و أن تبحث عن إشارتها بين أزقتها
و على صفحات أرصفتها
فالمدن هي البوتقة التي تحوي
و تترجم طموح الإنسان
وهي إنعكاس لرغبات و تطلعات
فمنهم من يبني مدينة من ورق
ومنهم من يبني مدينة من حجر
ومنهم من يبني مدينة من حب
ومنهم من يكتفي بالعيش في أي مكان يأويه
و هؤلاء مساكين فهم لم يعرفوا معنى الحياة
فالمدن الحضارية و منها بغداد
ليست تلك التي تحوي أبنية جميلة
و شوارع نظيفة فقط
بل هي التي تتلاقح فيها العقول المختلفة
و تنسجم فيها الأراء المتنافرة
و تتلاحم فيها القلوب المتباعدة
وبذلك تصبح مدينة حقيقية
تحملها في داخلك
لا التي تحملك في داخلها
و من يحمل مدينته في قلبه
فلن يشعر بالغربة ابدا
ولذلك فالمدن الحضارية
هي ترجمة لطموح الإنسان
و انعكاس لرغبات وتطلعات
و هذا ما نشاهده من مدن هجرها أهلها
بسبب تحطيم آمالهم و تطلعتهم
إلى مدن العدل و النظام
والمساواة و العيش الكريم
و حفاظ حقوق أجيال المستقبل
لذا يبدأ تاريخ المدن
عندما يبدأ الإنسان في تفكير في مستقبلها
و من هنا تحتاج منا وقفات
فأين أنت يا بغداد من هذا و ذاك
ولننظر كيف نقدم حلا لمشاكل بغداد
وكيف نحافظ على تراث إمرأة جميلة
وحضارة إنسان
نسأل نفسنا شنو الرابط
ما بين الماضي و الحاضر و المستقبل
و لماذا نحن نبحث عن المدينة الإنسانية
التي تحتوي الإنسان وتثبت رغباته
و متطلباته و تطلعاته باتجاه المستقبل
راح نشوف في لغة حوارية
ما بين تجربة العراق و تجربة العالم المتطور
أقعدنا ما يسمى باستراتيجيات التجديد الحضري
لتطوير المدن
أحنا غايتنا وهدفنا نريد ننقل الرعب و الخوف
من عيون و وجوه أبنائنا
إلى رسم الإبتسامة على وجوههم
إحنا كمعمريين دائما نميل
أنه نسلح البيئة الحضرية ليعيش بها الإنسان
نخلق بيئة صالحة تنتج إنسان سوي
فمن هذه الاستراتيجيات لراح نمرعليها
الاستراتيجية الأولى هي إعادة التطوير
المدن التي دمرتها الحروب
المدن التي عاشت سو تخطيط و سو تدبير
مثل بغداد
خاضت عدة حروب و هذا حال بغداد بل 2003
لما نجي ننطقل و نروح نشوف برلين
بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية
دمرت أكثر مما دمرت بغداد
شو سوو
هذا بناء الرايخستاغ
من أهم الأبنية الموجودة في برلين دمر
الألمان بعد التوحيد
تركوا كل مشاكلهم وخلافاتهم
تحولوا باتجاه بناء بلادهم وعمارمجتمعاتهم
بناء الرايخستاغ من أجمل أبنية حاليا
و الإضافة المبدعة لسارت فوقها
أضفتلها لمسة فكرية ومعنوية
خلت الإنسان الألماني أو الزائر يجي يفوت
واتجول في داخل البناء و يشوف البرلمانيين
وهم يطرحون الأفكار
معناها خلت الإنسان
جزء من المنظومة الحكومية
و هو صاحب القرار
و بذلك أصبحت برلين حاضرة من حواضر العالم
نرجع إلى بغداد و إلى الاستراتيجية الثانية
اللي هي إعادة التأهيل
عندنا أبنية هيكلها الإنشاء جيد
أو جزء من المدينة هيكل الإنشاء جيد
يعتازله انه اني أرفع من مكان توقيم تلي
يتناسب مع القرن الحادي و العشرين
عمارة الدفتردار من الأبنية المهمة
عندنا في بغداد على نهر دجلة
مع الأسف
من جينا نشتغل في القرن الحادي و العشرين
غلفناها بصفائح الألم من يوم الألكابوند
بألوان لا تمت بصلة للذوق العام
ليش؟ واحنا دنتألم
مدنتنا دات اتراجع يوم ورا يوم
الذوق العام دا اتراجع
كلنا مسؤولين عليه
ما نقدر نبعد الشبهة والتهمة عن أحد
كلنا دنساهم به
خل ننتقل و نشوف
نروح لفرنسا و نشوف باريس
باريس بقت حافظت على هويتها و مكانتها
وخصوصات
لما أرادوا يساوون باريس جديدة
و إرتفاعات عالية ناطحات السحاب
طلعوا خارج باريس القديمة
و نشوف أسلوب إعادة التأهيل
أحد الأزقة التقليدية في باريس
هذا الزقاق ما يختلف في شيء
عن أزقتنا في مركز بغداد التاريخي
المجاري في نص الطريق و أبنية متهالكة
بس شوفو نفس اللقطة للزقاق هذا
شون استراتيجيات إعادة التأهيل أعادو
رفعوا من مستوى البنى التحتية
و حسنوا الواجهات
و حسنوا الظروف المعيشية للإنسان
نرجع على الإستراتيجية الأخرى
إللي هيا الإملاء الحضري
لما نجي نريد ندخل مكون حضري جديد
إلى سياق قديم
من انباوع على مركزالرصافة القديمة
مجموعة من الأبنية مختلفة الارتفاعات
مختلفة الترز
مختلفة الألوان
هذا أحنا نسميه بالتصميم الحضري للمدينة
هذه عبارة عن فوضى حضرية
واحدة من الأبنية تصميمها جميل
بناية البنك المركزي
من أجمل تصاميم الأبنية اللي صارت عندنا
بس لكن لما نجي نباوع
هاوية السياق الحضري اللي يحطها
غير منسجمة
لأنه شارع الرشيد
بمجموعة من العناصر و المكونات
هاي جات في كفزى
تختلف عن سياق الحضري اللي يحطها
ننطقل إلى فيينا
و نشوف بناتة هاز هاوس
بناية جديدة
مصممة من المعماري هانس هولاين
أمام كنيسة كاتدرائية القديس اسطفان
في الداون تاون من جاء يريد يشتغل
إشتغل عمارة القرن العشرين
في نهايات القرن العشرين هي صممت و نفضت
بس بنفس الوقت
اجى متناسب هوية السياق ليحيطه
من حيث الفتحات
إرتفاع البناء
الأفاريز الأفقية
بل جت هويية سياق التقليدي عمارة منسجمة
في بعد أو ما يسمى هاي عندنا
المفاتيح المشتركة لأخلقها الحوار
ما بين القديم و الجديد
عندنا إستراتيجية أخرى
اللي هيا الحفاظ
وهي اللي تهمنا شوي
رحى انركز عليها
ونفوت في تفاصيلها
بناية سوق السراجين
في مركز الرصافة القديمة
من أجمل الأبنية الموجودة عندنا
ما أكتمكم سر
من جون الأجانب و الوفود الأجنبية
في مؤطمر بغداد عاصمة الثقافة العربية
و خدناهم جولة هناكة
يعني قلوا لنا
أنتم عندكم جوهرة
بس ما تعرفون تتعملوا و ايها
العالم يحسدنا على هذا الإرث الحضاري
و يعتبروه جزء من الإرث العالم
و طبعا كل مواثيق و قوانين
هذا كيفية التعامل وياه
هذا الخزين التراثي
هاي البيوت الشناشيل القديمة
اللي هي تراثنا
و تاريخنا اللي نعتز به المفروض
الآن في القرن الحادي و العشرين
تغلف بصفائح ألومنيوم
و بألوان ما طليق بالذوق العام
إرادا لوقفى خل نصفن بنا وبين نفسنا
احنا دنعمر مدينتنا
لودن نرجعها إلى الوراء
ننتقل و نشوف تجربة العالمية الأخرى
نروح إلى روما
روما بقت هي روما
روما الرومانية و روما القرون الوسطى
بقت نفس الإرتفعات
الهيمنة فقط لأبراج الكنائس
و الباقي كل سياق حضري
منخفض الإرتفاع
و نشوف مثل فونتانا دي تريفي
هذا مكان جاذب للبشر
الناس تستقربه
و تستمتع به
بقو حافضوا على كل تفاصيل
الأبدية اللي داير ما دايرها
ما أحد طلع عنا فكرة يريد ولله يسوي إستثمار
و يريد يسوي أبنية شاهقة الإرتفاع
لا هذا جزء من تاريخه
محد يفرط به
يؤسفني احنا بدينا نفرت بتاريخنا
إن كان بالإرهاب
إن كان بالسوء الطخطيط
إن كان بغزو الإستثمار
وعدم السيطرة عليه
بيازا الإسبانية
من أجمل و أروع الأماكن في روما
شوفو البشر اللي قاعدين بيها
شوفو البشر اللي يصولفون و يستمتعون
ناس تستقر تقعد
و يصبح مكان
لأنه ارتبط بذكريات
يعني روما طبعا هاي البيازات
بالفعل أكو روح خفيية
نحس بها لما نزوروها
ليش احنا مدننا هاي
الروح الخفيية بدينا نحاول
نتمسها و نقتلها
عندنا أصلوب آخر إللي هو الحماية
مدرسة المستنصرية
هذا الكنز إللي كلنا نعتز بيه
كنز العلم و الطفوق
و لمين خلالها خرجت أجيال
علمت العالم الغربي
بالقرن الواحد و العشرين
سنة ألفين و خمسة عشر
شوفو كيفية التعامل مع المدرسة المستنصرية
لما أرادوا يصرفون مياه الأمطار
خلوا هذه الأنابيب ضاهرة
تبعا وفق المواثيق الدولية
مجموعة من المواثيق
كل هاي المدن بنتكلم عليها
هي أكو مواثيق تعتمد عليها
مكتوبة من قبل منظمة الإيكوموس
و من قبل اليونسكو
هذا يجعل هذه االمنظمات الدوالية
تصحب إعترافها هكذا
إرث حضاري عالم
لأن ماعرفنا نتعامل وياه
و بالتالي صارت عندنا مكب للنفايات
شون يعني أقدر أجيب الصائح
شون أقدر أجيب إبن البلد يعيش في هذا المكان
ويستقر به و يستمتع به
والبيئة البحيطة اليه نافرة
غير جاذبة
ننتقل إلى براغ
ونشوف تجربتهم
براغ من أجمل الأماكن الموجودة في العالم
تقث محافظة إرتفاعات الأبراج الكنائس
و الباقي سياق حضري منخفض
ونشوف لما أرادوا يشتغلون
يعني أكيد المبنى يعتازله إدامة
و سيانة وترميم
لما جاو إرادوا يعالجون تصريف مياه الأمطار
صووه في مكان مخفي
والطولون
مثل لون الحجر اللي داير بيه ما دايره
و بالتالي ما صار عنصر مسيء
و نشوف لقطات لجسر تشارلز
من أجمل الجسور الموجودة
أحنا نعبر عليه نمشي
هذا صار مكان ناس تستقر بيه
يرسمون بورتريه
الناس دتستمتع وترتبط بذاكرتها
عندنا الأسلوب الآخرإللي هو الحماية
مدينة الكاظمية المقدصة
نموذج متفرد بالمالم
من نماذج الحضارة الإسلامية
شوفوالسياق الحضري يحيط
يوصل لحد الصور
للمرقب و المسجد
هاي مدينة الكاظمية
لبداية القرن العشرين ها الشكل
واحد من أبنيتها المهمة
إللي هو سوق الإستربادي
شوفو بدايتة القرن العشرين
بناية تراثية ناضرة بالحياة
و نشوفوها بالقرن الحادي والعشرين
بناية متهرئة مكب للنفايات
هذا الكل دينعكس عل البشر
إللي راح يعيش في داخلها
و بعدين جاو غلفوا واجهات الأبنية
في هذا المكان المقدص
بألوان ما طليق بمكان طاهر
و أساؤوا للبيئة الحضارية لتحيط به
بل الأدهى والأمر
الجهات المعنية مؤخرا
قبل حوالي ٣/٤ أشهر
مسحت جزء كبير من هذا المذيج التراثي
و خلتنا نخسر
جزء مهم من تاريخ و توراث مدينتنا
يعني احنا سياسة البلدوزر مدنلحق عليها
دائما ننادي بالحفاض
و هاي بسياسة البلدوزربسير أسرع من عندنا
و ديخلونا أمام الأمر الواقع
خل ننطقل و نشوف فينيجيا
شو تختلف عن الكاظمية
سياق تقليد قديم
بيازا سان مركو
هو الفضاء الحضري المهيمن على المدينة
بقت فينيجيا مثل ما هي
ما حد لعب بها
ما حد صور ارتفاعات عالية
ما حد غلف بألواح الألكابوند
ليش
لأن يعتزون
هذا تراثهم
و بالعكس هي مورد إقتصاد مهم
الناس تروح هناك على مود تشوف
هذا الإرث العالم المهم
و طبعا كل هاي وفق مواثيق دوالية
أكو ميثاق فينيجيا الممتلكات الأثرية
انكتب سنة 1965 و اشتغلوها بموجبة
بل يصرفون ملايين الدولارات
على حماية هاي الأبنية
بسبب الرطوبة و سعود مستوى مياه البحر
نرجع أكو أسلوب آخر إللي هو إعادة البناء
هذا قصر الزهور
قصر الملك فيصل
موقع الحارثية
يؤسفنا هذا قصر إللي هو جزء من تاريخنا
الامريكان ضربوه بصاروخ
أثناء الحرب
و تفلش
قبل سنتين ثلاث من فتت لهذا المكان
لقيته مزايليه بأكمله
يعلمونا شو نحافض على توراثنا
و قلتلهم أني أشكركم دتوعونا
بس أريتكم تنتبهون
علمو جنودكم
شون يحافضون على تراث الحضارات الأخرى
هاي الدعوة من هذا المكان
الامريكان إللي دمرو هذا المبنى التراثي
يعيدوه وفق إستراتيجية إعادة البناء
و خل نشوف شون
لما نجي ننتقل لدرسدن
شو سوو إعادة إستراتيجية البناء
هذا قصر الملكي في درسدن
بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية بقت أطلال
رجعوه الألمان
وفق إعادة إستراتيجية أسلوب إعادة البناء
مثل ماكان بجميع تفاصيله
بل ما نقدر نميز إنه هذا جديد مو القديم
بناية أخرى كنيسة فراون كرج
باكيت أطلال
و شوفوها شو رجعوها
من أجمل الأبنية
نرجع إلى الأسلوب الآخر
إللي هو إعادة التكيف بالإستعمال
المبنى التراثي يختلف عن الآثار
الآثار احنا نجي ننفرد داير ما داير و نطلع
بينما المبنى التراثي هو ماضي
مثل جدي و جدك
و بيبيتي و بيبيبتك
لازالو موجدين بالبيت
لازالو جزء من النسيج الإجتماعي
لازم نخليهم يواكبون التطور
و يعيشون حياتهم
هاي الأبنية في شارع حيفا
في ثمانينات القرن العشرين
انصرف على كل واحد ثلاث ونصف مليون دولار
على مود يحافظون عليه و يصينوه
وفق المواثيق الدولية
بس إيش صارعندنا
عبارة عن أبنية مفردة الإستخدام
إما مكاتب للأحزاب
أو أبنية إدارية
بينما المبنى التراثي لازم إكون بيه حياة
خل ننتقل للايبزيغ و نشوف
معمل القطن
دخل بلائحة التراث العالم
شوفو شو سووله
سووله عبارة عن بازار
للفنانين و منتليات
خلو البشر كلها تجي
لأن البشر هو إللي يعطى معنى للمكان
فالمكان بدون بشر ما له قيمة
أحنا يهمنا البشر
من هذا كل هذا
أحنا شو نريد
ليش دنادي بالتراث
ليش عندنا طموح
إنه تكون مدننا صالحة
نريد نعيد البسمة لوجوه أبنائنا
نريد نخليهم يعشون أجمل أيام حياتهم
هاي دعوة إلنا كلنا
أن نبدأ بأنفسنا
إصلاح أنفسنا
إصلاح مدننا
إصلاح أبنيتنا
إصلاح تراثنا و حضارتنا
على مود نكون فاعلين
ما أكتمكم سر بدينا أحنا كناس
يعني احتمالات شخصية
سوينا ميثاق النجف لحماية الممتلكات الأثرية
و يا أهل النجف
لما انحسو التدمير إللي ديصيب مدينتهم
فسوينا أول ميثاق دولي
لصيانة الممتلكات الأثرية
بس يأسفني إنه الجهات المعنية
ما دارت
لأن ما تريد أي شي يقيدها
هاي الدعوة
نريد أحنا نفتح ستارة على نهار جديد
نهاريحفظ للإنسان هيبته و كرامته
و نريد نعيد حضارتنا و تاريخنا و أجيالنا
إنه يكونون خزء من التغطية
خزء من آمال و تطلعات العالم المزدهر
أخيرا و ليس آخرا
مدي بساطي و املئي اكوابي
و انسي العتاب فقد نسيت عتابي
عيناكِ، يا بغدادُ منذُ طفولَتي
شَمسانِ نائمَتانِ في أهدابي
لا تُنكري وجهي فأنتَ حَبيبَتي
(تصفيق)
لا تُنكري وجهي ، فأنتَ حَبيبَتي
وورودُ مائدَتي وكأسُ شرابي
لا تظلمي وترَ الرّبابةِ في يدي
فالشّوقُ أكبرُ من يدي ورَبابي
قبلَ اللقاءِ كُنتِ حبيبَتي
وحبيبَتي تَبقينَ بعدَ ذهابي
و شكرا